all right. It is a very busy day today, but
I do have hatred mail for you, hatred, hate
mail. Of course, a quick reminder, a professional
voiceover artist interprets the various hate
mails that I get. Quick reminder
because we cling to our guns and our God,
but somehow totally cool with a billionaire
who wants to assault our why?
Hey Trey, it may be written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom,
so something in this week's hatred mail doesn't
sound quite right. Something about it strikes
me as maybe an insincere detail that the hatred
is providing to us. Let's take a listen.
Hey David, why don't you use some of that
Jew insider capital with Google and stop their
algorithm from screwing your channel over?
Clearly, David is controlled opposition. David,
I'm a beautiful woman, mostly black in the
past. I dated every race, but absolutely no
Jews or do you meant attracted
[inaudible]
your videos are re decile is, well,
listen, thank you for clarifying that. You
don't date Jews, but why do I have a feeling
that the hatred isn't really the beautiful
black woman that they claim to be? Uh, I don't
know. I, I have a little bit of trouble believing
that fight. Hatred, autism with the coupon
code hatred at 40 H a T R I O T four zero.
That's a coupon code, which will save you
40% off of any membership@joinedpacman.com
but it makes the hatreds cry because they're
few tile attempts to take down the show clearly
are failing a hatred 40 for any membership.